always been a team guy i've always been  a great teammate and i'm gonna continue  to do the same thing  and you you hope to be able to play  right away you know you were close last  week i was close last week you know i  hope to be able to you know play this  week versus the titans on sunday night  will you always have super bowl 50 will  that would be we always have super bowl  50. um  you know seeing the pictures when i was  walking out it just  made me tear up you know but we always  got  we always got super bowl 50.  i always got broncos country  and um yeah  is there hope then as this thing you saw  with peyton last week that someday  there's a bow that ties with your ring  of fame or hall of famer that's what  it's all about for sure  thank you vaughn